Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I like him personally, but I think he's as mad as a cut snake. What's the bugger going to say next? That's a random Australian talking about my co-presenter, Tom Holland, quoting Bob Hawke, Prime Minister of Australia, talking about another Prime Minister of Australia many years later, Tony Abbott. So Australians, Tom, if you've ever
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我个人挺喜欢他的，但我看他简直疯得像条被砍断的蛇。这混蛋接下来又要说出什么惊人之语？这是个随机的澳大利亚人在谈论我的联合主持人汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），并引用了澳大利亚前总理鲍勃·霍克（Bob Hawke）多年后评价另一位澳大利亚前总理托尼·阿博特（Tony Abbott）的话。所以澳大利亚人，汤姆，如果你曾
watched debates from the Australian legislature, they have a splendid way with words. I haven't really, but I have watched, obviously, Ash's series. So I've seen how Australians behave to visiting English cricketers.
看过澳大利亚议会的辩论，就会发现他们有着极其精彩的言辞。我其实没怎么看过，但我显然看过阿什（Ash）的系列节目。所以我见识过澳大利亚人是如何对待来访的英格兰板球运动员的。
Political sledging. They'reicketers. Political sledging. They're absolutely brilliant at political sledging. Yeah, sledging is the great Australian art. Yeah. Mental disintegration. So for our overseas listeners who don't know what sledging is, sledging is basically just abuse. Abuse.
政治垃圾话。他们是。板球运动员。政治垃圾话。他们在政治垃圾话方面绝对是高手。对，垃圾话是伟大的澳大利亚艺术。对。精神瓦解。所以对于不知道什么是垃圾话的海外听众来说，垃圾话基本上就是辱骂。辱骂。
Yeah. So you were quoting Bob Hawke. Yeah, and that's where we got to yeah so we've been going through uh australia's wartime and post-war prime ministers um we were planning to do it in one episode then we were planning to do it in two episodes um but there are so many australian prime ministers that we'd have to do in three and we've come now to probably the prime the australian prime minister who to the average pom yeah would be the kind of the platonic ideal of an australian he's the paradigm of an australian prime minister he's kind of
对。所以你刚才引用了鲍勃·霍克的话。对，我们说到这儿了。我们一直在梳理澳大利亚的战时和战后总理们……我们原本打算用一集来做，后来又打算用两集，但澳大利亚的总理实在是太多了，我们不得不分三集来做，而我们现在讲到的这位，大概是普通英国人（pom）心目中澳大利亚人的柏拉图式理想典型，他是澳大利亚总理的范例，他有点像
square george craggy loves a pint and in fact i mean his great feat uh he was a road scholar at oxford um he uh he set the world record for downing a yard of ale in 11 seconds. He did it in 11 seconds. So just for people who don't know, which I assume is 99% of people, a yard of ale, it's a very thin, long glass. And I think they have it at the Turf Tavern in Oxford. Tom, have you ever been to the Turf, a kind of classic Oxford pub? They have it behind the bar.
身材敦实、粗犷豪迈、酷爱一杯啤酒的人，事实上——他的一大壮举是——他是牛津大学的罗德学者，他曾在11秒内喝光了一码长的啤酒（yard of ale），创下了世界纪录。他用了11秒。所以，对于那些不知道（我猜是99%的人）的人来说，“一码长的啤酒”是一种非常细长的高脚玻璃杯。我想牛津的草皮酒馆（Turf Tavern）里就有这东西。汤姆，你去过草皮酒馆吗？那是那种典型的牛津酒吧。吧台后面就摆着这个。
And I think that's the yard of ale that Bob Hawke downed. I mean, it's a colossal amount. Yeah, because there's photos of him up there, I think, doing it. Exactly. And he downed it in 11 seconds. And as a feat, I mean, that is unsurpassed. I mean, that was a world record. I think it still is, isn't it?
我想那就是鲍勃·霍克喝光的那杯啤酒。我的天，那可是极其巨大的一杯。对，因为那里挂着他当时喝这杯酒的照片，我想是的。没错。而且他只用了11秒就喝光了。作为一个壮举，这可以说是空前绝后的。我的天，那可是世界纪录。我想现在依然是吧？
I'm not sure. I'm not sure if it's been beaten. But anyway, Bob Hawke. So in our previous podcast about Australia, certainly in the first one, which was less about trousers and more about genuine kind of themes of Australian political history, we talked about the religious stuff, which I know obviously sort of you enjoy. And how many of them, how many Australian, senior Australian politicians came from religious
我不确定。我不确定这个纪录有没有被打破。不过总之，讲回鲍勃·霍克。在我们之前关于澳大利亚的播客中，尤其是第一集（那一集较少涉及裤子，更多聚焦于澳大利亚政治史的宏大主题），我们谈到了宗教相关的内容——我深知你对此显然挺感兴趣。以及其中有多少人、有多少澳大利亚的高级政客出身于宗教背景，或者在那种背景下，他们或许曾背弃宗教，但内心深处依然保留着某种使命感之类的情愫。这非常符合实际。我的天，鲍勃·霍克看起来像是那种嗜酒如命、热爱烧烤的“澳大利亚先生”。但他的父亲是一位公理会牧师，他从小就生活在那种几乎令人窒息的宗教狂热氛围中。所以他的父亲，据他的传记作家说
backgrounds or backgrounds in which they had maybe abjured their religion and there was still a kind of sense of mission and stuff. And that's very true. I mean, Bob Hawke appears to be this kind of hard drinking, you know, barbecue loving Mr. Australia. But his father was a congregationalist pastor and as a as a boy he was brought up in this atmosphere of um of of sort of almost sort of suffocating religious intensity so his his um his his father told him according to his biographer
告诉他……他应该相信天父的慈爱，天堂就在他身边的这一切。他完全是在这种氛围中长大的，对吧？所以听了这些，你大概不会感到惊讶：我认为左翼的政策制定方式中有着极其强烈的基督教基调。你知道，霍克基本上——这正是他政治理念的本质，那是这些基督教原则的世俗化版本。我认为这绝对是真的。所以据说他在一个叫博德敦（Border Town）的地方长大，
that um he should believe in the fatherhood of god and the heaven was all around him and all this kind of thing and he absolutely grows up in that atmosphere right so it won't surprise you to hear that obviously i think that there's an incredibly christian strain within the left's approach to policy you know hawk is essentially i mean that's that's what his politics is, is a secularized version of those kinds of Christian principles. I think that's absolutely true. So apparently when he was a boy growing up in,
他童年是在哪里度过的？他在一个叫博德敦的地方长大。他获得了去珀斯上学等诸如此类的奖学金。但当他还是个男孩时——对澳大利亚标准来说，这些可算不上什么光鲜亮丽的地方。但即使是在他还是个男孩的时候——对澳大利亚标准来说，这些可算不上什么光鲜亮丽的地方。但即使在他还是个男孩时，由于他极其聪明，
what's he growing up? He's growing up in a place called Border Town. And he's, he has gets a scholarship to school in Perth and so on. But when he's a boy, I mean, these are not sort of glamorous places by Australian standards. But even when he's a boy, I mean, these are not glamorous places by Australian standards. But even when he's a boy, because he's so clever,
他的家人常开玩笑说，他将来一定会成为总理。他前往西澳大利亚大学（University of Western Australia）学习法律。有一天他骑着摩托车回家，突然觉得身体有些不对劲。接着他遭遇了一场车祸，一场可怕的车祸。他差点丧命。他在生死边缘挣扎了数日。他的母亲对他说：“你大难不死，这是上帝天意的显现。”
his family joke, and they'll say he'll be prime minister one day. And he goes off to the University of Western Australia to study law. And he's riding home on his motorbike when he feels something wrong. And he has this crash, this terrible crash. And he almost is killed. He spends days between life and death. And his mother says to him, you've been spared and it's a sign of God's providence.
霍克对此深信不疑。他后来回忆说：“我坚信上帝饶了我的性命。”他认为自己被赋予了第二次生命，并决心绝不浪费。这基本上促使他投身于慈善公益事业等等。于是他加入了——这并没有阻止他喝酒，对吧？这并没有阻止他。因此，他在1963年真的患上了酒精中毒。
And Hawke absolutely believes it. He says later, I firmly believe that God had spared my life. He thinks he's been given this new chance and he's determined not to waste it. And that basically drives him into sort of good works and so on. So he joins- It doesn't stop him drinking, does it? It doesn't stop him. So he literally has alcohol poisoning in 1963.
确实如此。但到了那个时候，他也已经放弃了自己的信仰。你知道为什么吗？他随基督教青年世界大会（World Conference of Christian Youth）去了印度。他大为震惊的是，基督教青年世界大会的成员们竟然过得非常滋润。你知道的，他们住在高档地方，而且以我对他的了解，估计每天晚上都在纵情狂欢。周围人们的贫困与这种奢华形成了鲜明对比，深深震撼了他。
Yeah, he does. But he's also, by that point, he's given up his faith. Because do you know why? He went to India with the World Conference of Christian Youth. And he was really shocked that the World Conference of Christian Youth were having a great time. You know, they're staying in nice places and presumably knowing him getting lashed every night. He's struck by the contrast with the poverty of the people around them.
他觉得这根本无法调和。于是他基本上失去了信仰。但就像你说的，汤姆，他保留了那种使命感。使命感……使命感，对。这把他引向了工会运动……工会。我们在昨天的惠特拉姆政府与惠特拉姆事件的讨论中曾简要提到过他。他曾是一位非常显赫的工会领袖，这为他日后涉足政坛提供了跳板。不仅如此，他还有个有趣的特点：他非常亲美。是的，我注意到了。
And he thinks he can't reconcile this. And he basically loses his faith. But as you say, Tom, he retains that sense of mission. His sense of mission sense of mission yeah um the and but he sort of that that that brings him into trade unionism and trade yeah and so we we talked we mentioned him briefly in the uh discussion of whitlam gov whitlam affair yesterday uh he was very prominent trade union leader um and that provides him with the springboard then to to enter politics um but he's also interesting he's's very pro-American. Yeah, I saw this.
他其实可以说是美国的一名线人。所以，这是一种有趣的组合。但在澳大利亚政坛（正如在英国政坛一样），存在着这样一种传统：那种极其自觉的爱国主义——在澳大利亚，当然反共情绪更甚——那种亲西方联盟的左翼政治，比如詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）。我的意思是，詹姆斯·卡拉汉、丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healey）那种类型。我认为霍克完全符合这种模式。
He's actually kind of informant to the US. So, yeah, kind of, you know, an interesting combination. But there is that tradition in Australian politics, as indeed in British politics, of sort of very self-consciously patriotic in Australia, obviously even more so anti-communist, kind of pro-Western alliance kind of left-wing politics James Callaghan yeah I mean James Callaghan Dennis Healy that kind of I mean
令人瞩目的是，他进入议会仅仅三年后就成为了总理。勒卡雷（Le Carré）的书迷们听到他所接替的工党领袖的名字一定会非常激动，那就是比尔·海登（Bill Hayden）。哦，我当时想说……不，我们不应该剧透，不过……《锅匠，裁缝，士兵，间谍》！他能做到这一点真是太棒了。对，霍克是一位极其成功的总理。
I think Hawke absolutely kind of um conforms to that pattern it's remarkable that he enters parliament only three years before he becomes prime minister yeah and fans of Le Carré will be very excited to learn the name of the labor leader who he replaces which is bill hayden oh i went i went no we shouldn't give it away but uh tinker taylor soldier spy yeah it's great that he does yes um and hawk is an incredibly successful prime minister yeah but interestingly so as you say he's got this kind of, you know, this image of being the plain speaking, craggy. I mean, he is. He really is a man's man, isn't he? With all this, these drinking feats, even though he's given up booze.
但有趣的是，正如你所说，他有着直言不讳、饱经风霜的形象。我的天，他确实如此。他真的是个纯粹的男子汉，不是吗？有着各种豪饮的壮举，尽管他后来已经戒了酒。
Yeah, he gives it up. He pledges to give it up when he enters parliament and he sticks to that. Yeah. Until he leaves office. But his politics are a really interesting mix because he basically revives and intensifies the universal health care that Gough Whitlam had tried to pioneer in the 70s. But also in his economic stuff, that looks all very reforming and stuff. But it's actually not that dissimilar from what the battery government is doing yeah are doing is doing in britain so floating the australian dollar deregulating the economy bringing down tariffs yeah bringing down barriers all that sort of stuff basically opening the australian economy up to globalization into the economic trends of the late 20th century you know he's doing it from a left-wing sort of um perspective but it's not really that dissimilar
对，他戒了。他在进入议会时发誓戒酒，并且说到做到。直到他卸任为止。但他的政治理念是一个非常有趣的混合体。他基本上恢复并强化了高夫·惠特拉姆（Gough Whitlam）在70年代率先尝试的全民医疗保健制度。不仅如此，在经济政策方面，虽然看起来充满了改革色彩，但实际上与撒切尔政府在英国所做的事情并没有太大区别：让澳大利亚元汇率自由浮动、放松经济管制、降低关税、打破壁垒，诸如此类。基本上是将澳大利亚经济向全球化和20世纪末的经济大趋势敞开大门。他是从左翼的视角来做这件事的，但从根本上看，这与撒切尔和杰弗里·豪（Geoffrey Howe）在20世纪80年代初从右翼立场出发所做的事情并没有太大区别。
from what thatcher and jeffrey how we're doing in britain from a right-wing standpoint in the early 1980s um and it's and it's funny that the people so rarely draw parallels between the two because you're so imprisoned by kind of partisanship well i think also because uh the example of hawk and then keating who succeeds him are so influential on new labor in britain yeah i think that's right but you yeah i mean it's it's it's it's a fascinating parallel really is but you mentioned keating yeah i mean that's a great partnership isn't it i mean that's one of that that's the arguably the great partnership well it's the partnership that goes wrong so again a bit a bit like, I mean, I'm sorry for Australian listeners endlessly reducing it to parallels with New Labour,
有趣的是，人们很少将这两者进行类比，因为大家都被党派偏见深深局限了。不过我也认为，因为霍克以及接替他的基廷（Keating）两人的榜样作用，对英国的新工党产生了非常深远的影响。是的，我也觉得是这样。但你提到了基廷，那是极佳的政治伙伴关系，不是吗？可以说是最伟大的合作伙伴关系之一。好吧，这是那种最终走向破裂的伙伴关系。所以，这又有点像——抱歉，对于澳大利亚听众来说，我总是把这一切简化为与新工党进行类比，
but there's a kind of Blair Brown dynamic going on there. So the interesting thing about Hawke is that he, as you say, was a Rhodes Scholar. He didn't really like Oxford and didn't like the British, I think. No, and so he legislates to remove the last kind of links to… Well, he gets rid of the anthem, doesn't he? He says at one point, it's absolutely ridiculous that basically remove uh you know the last kind of links to when he gets rid of the anthem doesn't he yeah the um he says at one point it's absolutely ridiculous that basically when the british win some win an
但那里确实上演着一种布莱尔与布朗式的动态关系。关于霍克，有趣的一点是，正如你所说，他曾是一名罗德学者。他其实并不太喜欢牛津，我想他也不喜欢英国人。没错，所以他通过立法消除了与……好吧，他废除了国歌，不是吗？他曾在某个时候表示，当英国人赢得奥运会金牌时，大家起立奏响《超度女王》（God Save the Queen），而如果我们击败了他们，奏的居然还是《超度女王》，这简直荒谬绝伦。
olympic gold they get up and it's god save the queen if we beat them it's also god save the queen um which i think is probably fair enough but but um i think partly because he's a road scotland he's so clever and he's so successful and all of this stuff, he can play the part very happily of the ordinary guy because he's got nothing to lose. So he doesn't have any psychological hangups about people thinking he's stupid or anything. So he can sort of say, well, all I'm interested in is gambling, watching loads of sports, smoking cigars, obviously would have been alcohol in the old days so he can do all that but his treasurer and his political partner paul keating can't do all that because he yeah because he um he's catholic irish descent working class and he leaves school at 14 so his father yeah his father was a boiler maker and he i mean to leave school at 14 and to be involved in
我认为这话说得大概挺在理的。不过我想，部分是因为他是罗德学者，极其聪明且极其成功，所以他可以非常轻松地扮演普通人的角色——因为他没什么好失去的。他没有任何心理包袱，不用担心别人会觉得他愚蠢之类的问题。因此他可以直言不讳地说：“我感兴趣的只有赌博、看各种体育比赛、抽雪茄——当然，在过去日子里还得加上喝酒。”他可以尽情做这些事。但他的财政大臣和政治伙伴保罗·基廷（Paul Keating）却无法如此，因为他——因为他出身爱尔兰天主教工薪阶层，14岁就辍学了。他的父亲是一名锅炉工。14岁就辍学，却能在20世纪80年代和90年代的澳大利亚政坛崭露头角，那一定……基廷显然有着非常强烈的“我是靠自己一路拼搏爬上来的，我没有享受到任何优势”的心态。但正如你刚才所说，霍克去过牛津，履历上显而易见拥有各种学术背景，但他却能扮演平民硬汉的角色。
australian politics in the 1980s and 1990s i mean that must he yeah heating clearly has a very very strong sense of i've i've fought and scrapped my way up i haven't had any advantages but also you you was you were saying so hawk who has been to oxford and is transparently you know he has all kinds of academic credentials can play the larrikin. Yeah. You know. So after he leaves office, one of his favourite stunts is to go to cricket grounds and drown in tarpines in, again, 11 seconds or something.
你懂的。所以在卸任之后，他最喜欢的恶作剧之一就是去板球场，在11秒左右的时间里再次一饮而尽整杯啤酒。
Yeah. The entertainment of fans. There's great video footage of him doing that. Whereas Keating, although he is this, you know, he has kind of the image of a kind of a tough street fighter. He loves Marla. He collects French antique clocks. So really the pair of them are such fascinating and impressive men.
为了娱乐粉丝。网上有他做这件事的精彩视频片段。而基廷虽然有着强硬街头斗士的形象——他酷爱马勒的音乐，还收藏法国古董钟表——所以这两个人实际上都是极其迷人且令人印象深刻的政治家。
Yeah. I mean, their record is really extraordinary. And it's under them really that australia comes to seem i think to to countries in europe and america who previously might not have paid much attention to australia that they're very very interested in what they're doing that they're socially progressive and they're kind of um economically liberal which essentially establishes the template for the kind of government you know the third way yeah for clinton exactly yeah schroder um well and they schroder's not a name we bandy around on this podcast but he would
对。我的天，他们的政治政绩真的非同寻常。正是在他们执政期间，澳大利亚开始引起欧洲和美洲国家的关注。在此之前，这些国家可能并没有给予澳大利亚太多关注，而现在他们对澳大利亚正在做的事情表现出极大兴趣——他们社会进步且经济自由，这基本上为后来的克里特克政权模板奠定了基础——也就是第三条道路，对吧？对克林顿来说正是如此。施罗德……
but i mean he that's pretty much what he did it is it is i mean you know he in at the time he was seen as very successful leader so um australia blazes the path there um but this kind of homicidal Game of Thrones aspect to Australian party politics that we mentioned in the previous episode, Hawke ends up being assassinated by Keating, his long-term mate. Well, they'd had an agreement, hadn't they, called the Kirribilli.
好吧，施罗德不是我们在播客里经常挂在嘴边的名字，但他确实——我的意思是，这几乎就是他所做的事。确实如此。你知道的，当时他被视为一位非常成功的领导人，所以澳大利亚在那里开辟了一条道路。然而，澳大利亚政党政治中那种带有谋杀色彩的《权力的游戏》般的宫斗剧码——我们在上一集里提到过——最终导致霍克被他的长期搭档基廷刺杀。好吧，他们之前曾达过一项协议，叫做基里比利协议（Kirribilli）。
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that correctly. That's the Prime Minister's house in Sydney. They'd had this agreement in 1988. Very, very... So I know you've already apologised for the constant parallels, but it's very Granita to British listeners, the Blair-Brown Pact. And this pact basically was that Hawke would hand over
我不知道我有没有发音正确。那是位于悉尼的总理官邸。他们在1988年达成了这项协议。非常、非常……我知道你已经为不断的类比道过歉了，但这对于英国听众来说，简直太像布莱尔与布朗之间的“格拉尼塔公约”（Granita Pact）了。这项协议基本上规定，霍克将权力移交
to Keating, and he didn't. He basically said to him – Occupation of the crease. Yeah, yes. I'm not throwing away my wicket. And Keating, you know, tries these kind of – does this leadership challenge in the summer, I think, in 91, when the economy is actually already beginning to start to turn.
给基廷，但他却没有。他基本上对基廷说——我坚守阵地。对，是的。“我绝不会轻易放弃我的门票。”而基廷呢——你知道的，在91年的夏天，当经济其实已经开始出现好转迹象时，基廷发起了这次领导权挑战。
So the economic miracle of the 80s is beginning to fade. Keating challenges Hawking. He doesn't win at first, does he? But then he does win a second time in the second challenge at the end of 91 in December. And becomes prime minister. And becomes prime minister. And Keating was an absolute hate figure, wasn't he, for the British tabloids?
所以80年代的经济奇迹开始消退。基廷向霍克发起了挑战。他一开始并没有获胜，对吧？但在91年底（12月）的第二次挑战中，他确实获胜了，并成为了总理。并成为了总理。而基廷对于英国小报来说，绝对是个招人痛恨的人物，不是吗？
Yes. Well, so, I mean, he's, as we said, kind of of Irish descent. So there's a definite, you know, that, that, that strain of anti-British resentment of, um, Britain as a class ridden, monarchical, uh, antiquated crumbling empire. Yeah. Um,
是的。好吧，正如我们所说，他是爱尔兰后裔。所以其中绝对有一种对英国的怨恨情绪——把英国视作一个阶级分明、君主制、陈旧且正在崩溃的帝国。
it's, it's definitely a motivating factor for him. We mentioned in the first episode about the, um, the Anglo Australian bust up over who was responsible for the debacle at Singapore, um, in the Second World War. And Keating had very strident views on that, that it was the fault of the British.
这绝对是推动他行动的动力之一。我们在第一集里提到过，在第二次世界大战期间，关于谁应对新加坡惨败负责，英澳之间曾爆发过激烈的争吵。基廷对此有着非常激进的观点，认为这完全是英国人的错。
And he's very keen to see the Queen removed as head of state and for Australia to become the Republic. He says Britain is the country which decided not to defend the Malayan Peninsula, not to worry about Singapore, and not to give us our troops back to keep ourselves free from Japanese domination. So there's absolutely no shreds of the old kith and kin from Paul Keating. No, none of that. He's the opposite of Robert Menzies. And so the Queen comes on a state visit in 1992,
他非常急切地希望取消英国君主作为国家元首的地位，让澳大利亚成为一个共和国。他说：“英国是那个决定不保卫马来半岛、不担心新加坡、也不把我们的军队还给我们以保护我们免受日本统治的国家。”所以从保罗·基廷身上，你绝对找不到任何关于血浓于水的旧日情怀。没有，一点也没有。他与罗伯特·孟席斯（Robert Menzies）截然相反。因此，当女王在1992年进行国事访问时，
and Keating tells her, basically, you know, we want a republic. And the Queen plays it very well. I mean, she says, fine, you know, whatever you want to do. But the thing that gets the British tabloids going is that Keating touches Her Majesty. But he touches her, I mean, let's be honest. Not like John Gorton had touched Liza Minnelli. He touches her in the most fleeting and sort of barely noticeable way. He puts his hand for a moment. And it's concerned, isn't it? I mean, he's concerned that she doesn't fall.
基廷直接告诉她：“我们想要一个共和国。”而女王表现得非常大度。我的天，她说：“好的，随你们便，你们想怎么做都行。”但真正让英国小报炸锅的是，基廷居然碰触了女王陛下。他碰了她——说实话，并非像约翰·戈尔顿（John Gorton）碰莉莎·明尼利（Liza Minnelli）那样。他只是进行了最短暂、几乎难以察觉的轻触。他的手放了一下。那是出于关心，对吧？我的天，他是担心她摔倒。
He's helping her. He ushers her down. A chivalrous gesture. Or something like that, with his hand for a second on her back. And everybody then says... And the camera slaps it. Yeah.
他在帮扶她。他扶着她走下台阶。这是一个充满骑士精神的举止。或者诸如此类的动作，他的手在她的背上放了一秒钟。然后所有人都在说……而摄像机捕捉到了这一幕。
And so they call him the Lizard of Oz. The Lizard of Oz. Yeah, and everybody says everybody says oh my god it's absolutely disgraceful typical australian behavior trying to grope our dear queen but i mean it's hard to feel too sorry for keating because um i mean he really gives as good as he gets he is he is fabulous with the insults well so the opposition leader john houston this is a very famous quote in Australia, says basically, why won't you call an early election? And Keating says, I want to do you slowly. The answer is, mate, I want to do you slowly.
于是他们管他叫“澳大利亚蜥蜴”（Lizard of Oz）。澳大利亚蜥蜴。是的，每个人都在惊呼：“天哪，这简直无耻至极！典型的澳大利亚人行为，居然试图对我们亲爱的女王图谋不轨！”但说实话，很难对基廷产生太多同情，因为他向来是人敬我一尺我敬人一高，他的讽刺挖苦功夫绝对是一流的。反对党领袖约翰·休森（John Hewson）——这是澳大利亚非常著名的一句名言——当时质问他：“你为什么不提前举行大选？”基廷回答说：“老兄，实话告诉你，我想慢慢折磨你。”
You're very good at this, Tom. I shall defer to you on the Australian insult impersonation. So during the 80s, the leader of the opposition was a guy called Andrew Peacock uh and he said the leader of the opposition is more to be pitied than despised the poor old thing the liberal party of australia ought to put him down like a faithful old dog because he is no use to it and of no use to the nation um and then another leader of the opposite actually i think it may still be andrew peacock again he just said i did not slither out of the cabinet room like a mangy maggot um he uh he described john howard who subsequently became a liberal prime minister there's a little desiccated coconut uh and it
汤姆，你太擅长这个了。在模仿澳大利亚人的刻薄言辞方面，我得向你甘拜下风。所以在80年代，反对党领袖是一个叫安德鲁·皮考克（Andrew Peacock）的人。霍克曾评价说：“反对党领袖与其说是招人恨，不如说是招人怜悯。这个可怜的家伙，澳大利亚自由党应该像对待一条忠诚的老狗一样给他实施安乐死，因为他对党毫无用处，对国家也毫无价值。”然后另一位反对党领袖——其实我觉得这可能还是指安德鲁·皮考克，他曾反唇相讥：“我可不是像一只生病的蛆虫一样从内阁会议室里溜出来的。”他曾把约翰·霍华德（John Howard，后来成为自由党总理）形容为“一颗干瘪的小椰子”，
was incredibly rude about john howard had dennis heady type um eyebrows and george pompadour yeah style eyebrows i will never get to the stage of wanting to lead the nation standing in front of the mirror every morning clipping the eyebrows here and clipping the eyebrows there with janet and the kids it's like spot the eyebrow oh god so good good i mean good knock about stuff but he called the the liberals a motley dishonest crew he called the national party dummies and dimwits desperados and he said of another um opposition politician peter costolo being attacked by him was like being flogged with warm lettuce yeah and jeffrey howe style compared him to a dead sheep being savaged by a dead sheep
并且对约翰·霍华德那种丹尼斯·希利式的浓密眉毛和乔治·蓬帕杜式的发型刻薄至极：“我绝不会沦落到每天早晨站在镜子前，跟珍妮还有孩子们一起，这修修眉毛那剪剪眉毛的地步，来渴望领导这个国家。这简直就像在玩‘找眉毛’的游戏！”天哪，太精彩了。这绝对是精彩的针锋相对。但他把自由党人称为“乌合之众、不诚实的草包”，把国家党人称为“木头人、笨蛋和亡命之徒”，他还这样评价另一位反对党政客彼得·科斯特洛（Peter Costello）：“遭到他的攻击，就像是被一条温热的生菜狠狠鞭笞了一番。”这简直和杰弗里·豪形容自己“就像是一只死羊被另一只死羊疯狂撕咬”有异曲同工之妙。
don't know who came first with that actually but actually the thing is that keating tom is a um he's a great character but also he is a substantial politician because he yeah he he not only does he embody a long-running kind of sort of a long-running strain in australian politics which is the sort of um i suppose populist reformist anti-british chippy chippy yeah chippy but chippy can be good as well as bad because so for example it's keating who in 1992 gives this hugely important landmark speech uh called the red fun park speech about aboriginal reconciliation which because we talked in the very first podcast six weeks ago on that we did on australian politics um we talked about racism and the
我不知道这句话究竟是谁原创的。但事实上，汤姆，基廷不仅是一个个性鲜明的伟岸人物，更是一位极具分量的政治家。因为他不仅体现了澳大利亚政坛长期存在的一种深层倾向——也就是那种民粹主义、改良主义、反英情绪兼具的自卑又自负的冲动——不过，这种冲动有时会带来坏结果，但也能带来好结果。例如，正是基廷在1992年发表了一篇具有极其重要里程碑意义的演讲，被称为“雷德芬公园演讲”（Redfern Park Speech），谈论的是关于澳大利亚原住民的和解问题。正如我们在六周前关于澳大利亚政治的第一期播客中讨论过的那样——我们谈到了种族主义和“白色澳大利亚政策”——基廷确实是第一位总理（当然，此前也有过特别是工党出身的总理曾试图正视这一问题），他是第一位真正竭尽全力去解决这一问题的总理。
white australia policy and keating really is the first prime minister i mean obviously there have been labor prime ministers in particular who've sort of faced up to it before but he's the first one who who goes really out of his way yeah and i want i wonder if it's um in a way the fact that he is seen as such a street fighter the fact that he has such a caustic tongue means that that when he does this it has a greater impact so rather like the fact that he's so obviously you know he's a labor politician he also famously says about the recession that it was um uh it was the recession we had to have which was a you know a phrase that the liberal party really tried to hang around his neck in the election of 93, which is the year after he becomes prime minister. But amazingly, he wins it.
我想知道这是否是因为——由于他被视作一名名副其实的街头斗士，拥有极其尖酸刻薄的口才——当他迈出这一步时，反而产生了更大的影响力。就像他极其坦率地承认的那样（他是一位工党政客），他曾有一句名言：关于那场经济衰退，他直言不讳地说“这是我们不得不经历的经济衰退”。这句话在1993年的大选中（也就是他上台的次年）被自由党人死死抓住并试图套牢在他身上。但令人惊异的是，他赢得了那场大选。
So it's a kind of John Major style election victory against the odds. So I think he's a very impressive, charismatic figure. He's sort of stuck with his approach, hasn't he? Because even now in the last few months, he's still quite vocal. He says Australia should pivot towards, he's very quite vocal. He says Australia should pivot towards – he's very much of the view that Australia should pivot towards Asia, towards China. He says our most important partner is not Britain or America,
所以这是一场类似于约翰·梅杰（John Major）式的、在逆境中取得的选举胜利。因此我认为他是一个极具震撼力、充满个人魅力的政治人物。他一直坚守着自己的政治主张，不是吗？因为即便到现在，在过去的几个月里，他依然相当活跃。他直言不讳地表示，澳大利亚应当将重心转向——他非常坚定地认为，澳大利亚应当将重心转向亚洲，转向中国。他说我们最重要的伙伴不是英国或美国，
it's Indonesia. When they signed – do you remember when the Australians, Scott Morrison, signed that AUKUS deal with Britain and America? Yeah. Keating came out and said, should never have signed this deal. We shouldn't be getting into bed with what he called the jaded and faded Anglosphere.
而是印度尼西亚。当时他们签署了——你还记得澳大利亚的斯科特·莫里森（Scott Morrison）与英美两国签署那个“奥库斯”（AUKUS）协议的时候吗？基廷当时公开站出来说：“根本就不应该签这个协议。我们不应该跟那个他所谓的‘疲惫不堪、日薄西山的盎格鲁-撒克逊世界’（Anglosphere）滚到一张床上去。”
And we should be doing deals with our Asian neighbours. Which is the perspective of New Zealand, pretty much. Yeah. So, yeah, that's the strain in Australia and New Zealand. He's Prime Minister until 96, when he loses the election to John Howard, the little desiccated coconut with the eyebrows. And John Howard is a, you know, I mean, he's a very, very long serving, very successful prime minister. So I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we will.
我们应该跟我们的亚洲邻居做生意。这基本上就是新西兰的立场。所以，这就是澳大利亚和新西兰政治中一直存在的某种思潮。他担任总理直到1996年，在选举中输给了约翰·霍华德——那个长着浓密眉毛的干瘪小椰子。而约翰·霍华德是一位任期极长、极其成功的总理。所以我想我们此时应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将迎来——
The final, the final segment of this mighty Antipodean odyssey through the history of Australian prime ministers. So we'll see you then. showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. G'day, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We have reached the reign of John Howard, who was Prime Minister for, it seemed like forever, didn't it? Yes. So 11 years, 1996 to 2007. I'll be frank.
这场伟大的南半球澳大利亚总理历史奥德赛之旅的最后一部分。我们一会儿见。娱乐八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，向您揭示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果您想收听无广告的音频、独家加更节目并提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们迎来了约翰·霍华德的执政时期，他担任总理的时间——感觉简直像有一个世纪那么漫长，对吧？是的。整整11年，从1996年到2007年。说句实话，
I don't find John Howard an immensely exciting political personality. What is exciting is that he's genuinely descended from convicts. So he's descended from a convict who was transported for stealing a watch. However, so he's a very substantial figure, isn't he? He's on the Anglophile, monarchist, conservative right. Great pals
我并不觉得约翰·霍华德是一个极具个人魅力的激进政治人物。但令人兴奋的是，他的祖上确实是不折不扣的流放犯。他的祖先是因为偷了一块表而被流放到澳大利亚的罪犯。尽管如此，他依然是一位极具分量的政治人物，不是吗？他属于亲英派、保皇派和保守派右翼。与乔治·W·布什是极好的朋友。
with George W. Bush. Yes. Very great pals. And he is the second longest serving Australian Prime minister after Menzies. And he's a rather Menzies-esque figure. More British than the British. I wouldn't go that far. I mean, I think essentially the fact, I think that rather like Blair and Brown benefit from Kenneth Clarke's stewardship of the economy. Yeah. I think that Howard benefits from Keating's stewardship of the economy.
是的，是非常要好的朋友。他是仅次于孟席斯的澳大利亚历史上任职时间第二长的总理。他其实是一个相当具有孟席斯色彩的人物。比英国人还要英国人。我不会走得那么远。我的意思是，我认为本质上——就像布莱尔和布朗受益于肯尼斯·克拉克（Kenneth Clarke）对经济的执掌一样，我认为霍华德也同样受益于基廷对经济的治理。
Yeah. I think that Howard benefits from Keating's stewardship of the economy. And I think that the Australian economy is in such good fettle for his premiership that essentially he doesn't really need to do anything. It just kind of chugs along. Yeah. Although he does, in foreign affairs, he's very activist, isn't he? Yeah, he's very into the war on terror.
是的，我认为霍华德受益于基廷对经济的治理。而且我认为由于在他任职期间澳大利亚经济状况极佳，他基本上无需做什么重大调整，经济就那样自行顺畅地运转下去了。不过在外交事务上，他确实非常积极主动，不是吗？是的，他对反恐战争非常热衷。
Yeah, he is. I mean, George Bush regards him as a personal friend during the height of the war on terror. And he's probably the most enthusiastic, most overtly enthusiastic. Because, I mean, Tony Blair does the sort of act of sort of, there's a sense of him agonizing about the right path, I suppose, isn't there? Howard's right, he's straight in.
确实如此。在反恐战争最激烈的高峰期，乔治·布什甚至将他视作个人密友。他大概是最狂热、最公开表现出热情的领导人。因为托尼·布莱尔还会表现出那种内心的纠结、似乎在寻找正确道路的痛苦挣扎，对吧？而霍华德则不同，他直接一头扎了进去。
Yeah, straight in there. He's a devout i suppose isn't that he's straight in yeah straight in there straight he's a devout christian howard and he's also very pleasingly for you tom a massive cricket fan yeah well this is a bit of a theme isn't it it is are there any australian prime ministers who haven't been who say i couldn't i hate it i can't stand cricket i'm sick i don't know there must be but maybe it's something that you can't admit i mean like british prime ministers you know can't admit they don't like football. They can, though. They can really.
是的，直接冲了进去。霍华德是一位虔诚的基督教徒，而且——对于你这个汤姆来说非常合心意——他还是一个狂热的板球迷。没错，这几乎成了一个固定主题了，不是吗？确实如此，难道还有哪位澳大利亚总理不是板球迷吗？会不会有人说“我讨厌板球，我简直对它深恶痛绝”？我不知道，肯定有这样的人，但也许这是那种在政坛无法公开承认的事吧？就像英国首相也不能公开承认自己不喜欢足球一样。其实他们是可以承认的。他们完全可以。
They know really. They will have to pretend. Look at Dave Cameron. Yeah, I couldn't even remember. Well, I mean, he's... Which one it was. Yes. One thing that rises and falls under Howard is the figure of Pauline Hanson.
他们其实心里明白。他们不得不假装热爱。看看大卫·卡梅伦（Dave Cameron）。对，我甚至都记不清了。好吧，我的意思是，他……到底是支持哪支球队来着。是的。在霍华德执政期间，有一个政治人物的声势大起大落，那就是宝琳·汉森（Pauline Hanson）。
Yes. She's kind of been aligned to the Liberal Party but she is very hostile to the end of the non-white the end of the white Australia policy I maybe maybe I'm being a bit unfair to them maybe it's a bit more nuanced than that but basically she's she is kind of Nigel Farage on steroids yeah that's right and and Howard is also, you know, he's well known in Europe for his very, very sort of stern immigration policy, isn't he? Yeah, but it gets sterner, which we'll come to. Right. So anyway, so basically what we're saying is we haven't got a lot to say about him.
是的。她某种程度上与自由党结盟，但她对终结“非白人移民政策”、结束“白色澳大利亚政策”抱有极大的敌意。也许——也许我对他们的评价有点不公，也许其中的情况比这更加微妙——但基本上，她可以说是“打了激素的奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）”。对，确实如此。而且霍华德在欧洲也因其极其严厉的移民政策而闻名，不是吗？对，但后来的政策变得更加严苛，我们稍后会讲到。所以，总而言之，我们对他的评价其实并没有太多好说的。
Well, even though he's a very substantial figure in Australia. But of course, with him, I think that's sort of the point, isn't it? Yes. in Australia. But of course, with him, I think that's sort of the point, isn't it? That his sort of stolidity, you know, he's a bald man with glasses. Yeah, he's the George V of Australian Prime Ministers. He absolutely is. I mean, he appeals to these people who are called Howard Battlers, and they
好吧，尽管他在澳大利亚是一位极具分量的政治人物。但当然，对于他而言，这大概正是重点所在，不是吗？是的。在澳大利亚。但当然，对于他而言，这大概正是重点所在，不是吗？他那种沉稳的作风——你知道的，他是一个秃顶、戴着眼镜的男人。是的，他简直就是澳大利亚总理当中的乔治五世。他绝对是的。他吸引的那些选民被称为“霍华德的底层抗争者”（Howard Battlers），他们
are, I suppose, the Australian equivalent of what in America people used to call Reagan Democrats. In Britain, you know, the Red Wall. We call it the Red Wall, don't we? And he appeals to these people who are sort of aspirational, striving. Working class. Yeah, sort of upper working class, lower middle class,
大概相当于美国人过去常说的“里根民主党人”（Reagan Democrats）。在英国，我们称之为“红墙”（Red Wall），对吧？他吸引的正是那些有追求、在奋发向上、渴望阶层上升的人群。工人阶级。对，大致是上层工薪阶层、下层中产阶级，
self-consciously kind of respectable. They like all the stuff about law and order. They like about strong borders, all that sort of stuff. They don't want anything airy-fairy. And he's very – I mean, it's a little bit like Robert Mensah's The Forgotten People, The Forgotten Australians. Anyway, so a long period of stolidity, of continuity. He wins four elections. Then he gets defeated and he actually loses his seat.
他们有着强烈的体面意识。他们喜欢所有关于法律与秩序的主张，喜欢强硬的边境管控政策，诸如此类。他们不需要任何虚无缥缈的东西。他非常——这有点像罗伯特·孟席斯的“被遗忘的人民”（The Forgotten People）、“被遗忘的澳大利亚人”。总之，这是一个沉稳、充满连续性的漫长执政期。他赢得了四次大选。然后他遭遇了失败，甚至连自己的国会议席都丢了。
So that's the end of his career. That's pretty extraordinary, isn't it? And in a further humiliation, he gets nominated by Australia and New Zealand to lead the International Cricket Council and he gets rejected. Really? Yeah. So very sad for him. Why was he rejected?
这可以说是他政治生涯的终结。这相当不寻常，不是吗？更具羞辱意味的是，澳大利亚和新西兰提名他去领导国际板球理事会（ICC），结果他竟然被拒绝了。真的吗？是的。所以这对他来说非常悲惨。他为什么会被拒绝？
Because this is when India is starting to really flex its muscles as the cricket superpower. Right. And I think they're fed up with, you know, Englishmen and Australians running the show. So I think, I can't't remember but i think that's i think that's the reason but a bit like you know a long the long reign of a medieval king being succeeded by absolutely bloody civil war this is what now happens in australian politics because yeah howard's reign ends and he's beaten in the election by labor, led by Kevin Rudd, who's an impressive figure, studied Chinese, spoke Mandarin, been a diplomat. But essentially, over the course of the 2010s, it's like the Wars of the Roses, Game of Thrones.
因为正是在那个时候，印度开始真正展现其实力，成为板球运动超级大国。而且我认为他们已经厌倦了英国人和澳大利亚人来掌控大局。所以我想——我记不太清了，但我想这就是原因所在。不过，有点像中世纪国王漫长的统治结束后紧接着爆发血腥内战那样，澳大利亚政坛如今也上演了这一幕。因为霍华德的统治结束了，他在大选中被工党击败。工党由陆克文（Kevin Rudd）领导，这是一个令人印象深刻的人物，曾学习中文、说得一口流利的普通话，还当过外交官。但基本上，在整个2010年代，澳大利亚政坛就像是《玫瑰战争》和《权力的游戏》。
It's just a kind of constant everyone knifing each other. People get assassinated, they come back to life, they kill the person who's assassinated them and so it goes on it's all a bit confusing well this is the culture of spills isn't it and i i i wonder whether it's just actually a um it becomes a kind of institutional cultural thing that once you've got into this kind of habit of having a spill every two years there's just no reason not to keep having them well it's like the roman empire in the third century a.d it is you know once you start bumping off emperors you think yeah why not just keep going yeah which they do it's weird it's weird because in a way i mean australia negotiates the 2008 crash perhaps more successfully than any other major industrialized nation so there's a you know the crash happens rudd brings in a
大家陷入了一种无休止的互捅刀子之中。人们被刺杀，然后又卷土重来，接着又干掉曾经刺杀自己的人，如此周而复始。这一切简直让人眼花缭乱。这就是所谓的“宫廷政变文化”（culture of spills），不是吗？我在想，这其实是不是已经变成了一种体制上的文化惯性——一旦你们养成了每两年就发生一次逼宫政变的习惯，那就没有什么理由再去阻止它继续发生了。这简直就像公元三世纪的罗马帝国一样。确实如此。一旦你开始习惯于把皇帝赶下台并做掉他们，你就会想：“对啊，为什么不一直这么干下去呢？”他们也确实这么做了。这太诡异了。说来也怪，因为从某种程度上讲，澳大利亚应对2008年金融危机的表现，可能比任何其他主要工业化国家都要成功。危机爆发了，陆克文推出了经济刺激计划，澳大利亚成功避开了经济衰退，而其他国家则纷纷陷入泥潭。然而，明显的压力和紧张局势依然存在。不过你也可以说，汤姆，正是澳大利亚社会原本的稳定，才纵容了这种近乎轻率的政治文化。
stimulation package and australia avoids recession while everybody else is kind of going tanking. And yet clearly there are strains and stresses. But maybe, I mean, that's, you could argue though, Tom, that the stability of Australian life is precisely what allows this culture of almost frivolous. Yeah, so it's a spectator show. Yeah, of almost sort of frivolous politics for its own sake. Although, I mean, the person who commits the first assassination, you would not describe as frivolous because that's Julia Gillard. From Bali. Yeah, so maybe.
对，这成了一场供人围观的宏大秀。这种近乎轻率、为了宫斗而宫斗的政治。不过，发动第一起暗杀事件的那个人，你绝对不能说她是轻率的，因为那是朱莉娅·吉拉德（Julia Gillard）。来自威尔士。是的，也许吧。
Is she the first Welsh prime minister since Lloyd George? I think she is because she's, yes. She moved to Australia when she was five, I think. And she got given a little toy koala and she dropped it. No. Where is it? On the ship. Where is it?
她是自劳埃德·乔治（Lloyd George）以来第一位威尔士裔女性总理吗？我想是的，因为她确实是。她五岁时随家人移居澳大利亚。据说当时有人送了她一只小考拉玩具，结果她把它弄丢了。不会吧。在哪儿弄丢的？在船上。在哪儿？
In the Pacific somewhere. Still there. At the bottom of the Pacific, yeah. So that was very sad. And she, going back to the religious theme, she's from a Baptist background. But I think she sort of gave up her faith. Well, she is is if you imagine the guardian will you ever seen your female as a female australian prime minister that's what
在太平洋的某个地方。现在还在那儿。在太平洋海底，是的。所以这挺让人伤感的。谈到宗教话题，她出身于一个浸信会家庭。不过我想她后来大概放弃了自己的信仰。好吧，她如果——如果你想象一下《卫报》，你见过哪位女性澳大利亚总理是这样的吗？她就是
she's like she's the guardian newspaper in human form she is yes um she's a lawyer she is uh feminist um and she doesn't have children she's not married she doesn't have children and this will become um a topic of criticism among people on the right of the liberal party yeah let's say um so she she is uh rudd's deputy prime minister she is the minister of education um and basically she ends up feeling that it's her moral duty to stab rudd in the back yeah so she does so she does um and she uh there's then a hung parliament and she's able to cobble together a majority by kind of sucking up to the green there's one green mp i think three independents um so very very slightly unstable government She's an okay prime minister, I think.
《卫报》的人格化化身。她确实是的。她是一位律师，是一名女权主义者。她没有孩子，未婚，也没有孩子。而这后来成了自由党右翼人士攻击她的主要话题。
She's always being attacked, isn't she? So there's sort of an air of controversy around her, as far as I recall, from the moment she became, partly, I suppose, because she'd become PM as a result of assassination. And she has this huge feud with Tony Abbott. So Tony Abbott is basically the daily mail in, in human form. So it's the guardian against the daily mail.
我们可以这么说。她是陆克文的副总理，担任过教育部长。基本上，她开始觉得将陆克文刺杀于背後是她义不容辞的道德责任。于是她这么做了，她真的下手了。随后出现了一个悬峙议会，她通过向绿党献殷勤勉强凑够了多数席位——当时好像有一个绿党议员和三名独立议员。所以这是一个极其不稳定的政府。我认为她算是一位合格的总理。
Yeah. But I think, I think, I mean, I think that, that she is the kind of, um, very well-educated progressive female leader who rubs the backs up,
她一直遭到各种攻击，不是吗？所以从她上台的那一刻起，她周围就弥漫着一种争议的氛围——部分原因大概是因为她是通过宫廷政变的方式才当上总理的。她和托尼·阿博特（Tony Abbott）之间有着巨大的宿怨。托尼·阿博特基本上就是《每日邮报》（Daily Mail）的人格化化身。所以这是《卫报》对阵《每日邮报》。
um, deplorables, as Hillary Clinton would describe them. So I think there is an element definitely of, we talked right at the beginning, of the way that the idea of mateship can be quite tough for women to negotiate. Yeah. And I think Gillard suffers from that.
对。但我认为，她基本上是一位受过良好教育的进步派女性领导人，而她的存在极大地刺激了那些——正如希拉里·克劳顿（Hillary Clinton）所描述的——“无药可救的乌合之众”（deplorables）的神经。所以正如我们在最开始讨论过的那样，澳大利亚那种强调“伙伴情谊”（mateship）的文化，对女性来说确实很难去适应和游刃其中。我认为吉拉德正是深受其害。
And it leads to probably the thing for which he's most famous which is a speech he gives in in parliament where she gets accused by tony abba of of being a misogynist and she's so kind of outraged by this the very idea that she could be a misogynist and it's abbott who's accusing of being misogynist that she kind of launches into this great peroration which goes viral yes i will not be lectured about sexism and misogyny by this man. By this man. If he wants to know what misogyny looks like, he doesn't need a motion in the House of Representatives.
这大概引发了他最著名的一件事，也就是他在议会中发表的一场演讲。当时她被托尼·阿博特指控为厌女者，她对此感到无比愤怒——有人竟然觉得她会是个厌女者，而且指责她的偏偏是阿博特——于是她便发表了一篇引发轰动的慷慨陈词：是的，这个男人休想对我说教什么性别歧视和厌女症。这个男人休想。如果他想知道什么是厌女症，他不需要去众议院提议案。
He needs a mirror. That's what he needs. It's a shame she doesn't do it in a Welsh accent. I know. I know. Anyway, so she's Prime Minister for three years. And then do you know who knifes her? Well, you do. You've got my notes. Is it Kevin Rudd? Yeah. That's very game of thrones he makes a comeback yes it's like henry the sixth succeeding out of the fourth you know it scrambles all your timelines so he he does that but he's
他只需要一面镜子。这就是他需要的。真遗憾她不是用威尔士口音说这番话的。我知道，我知道。不管怎样，她当了三年首相。然后你知道是谁背后捅刀子搞下台的吗？好吧，你当然知道。你拿着我的笔记呢。是凯文·陆克文吗？对。这非常《权力的游戏》，他卷土重来。是的，这就像亨利六世接替亨利四世一样，你知道的，这把你们所有的时间线都搞乱了。所以他他确实这么做了，但他
only got three months in power because he's then defeated by tony abbott i mean that was he he did it didn't he because he basically said we can't win an election under julia gillard yeah so he stabbed her in the back and then he promptly lost the election himself. Yes. Yes. And then, so Tony Abbott, so Tony Abbott is, so Tony Abbott, I suppose you would say, is a very good representative of that other strain in Australian politics that we talked about from the beginning, which is much more overtly pro-British.
只掌权了三个月，因为随后他就被托尼·阿博特击败了。我的意思是，他他确实这么做了，不是吗？因为他基本上说过“我们在朱莉娅·吉拉德的带领下赢不了大选”，是的，所以他背叛了她，然后他自己很快也输掉了大选。是的。是的。然后，托尼·阿博特，托尼·阿博特，所以托尼·阿博特，我想你会说，他是我们从一开始就谈到的澳大利亚政治中另一种政治传统的优秀代表，那种传统要明显亲英得多。
I mean, he's got, he's... Well, he is, I mean, he's born in London. Yeah, and his father is English. Yeah. And he's another Rhodes Scholar, Queen's Oxford. Yeah. Again, there's the religious thing, Tom.
我的意思是，他……好吧，他，我的意思是，他出生在伦敦。是的，而且他父亲是英国人。是的。他又是罗德学者，牛津大学王后学院的。是的。汤姆，这里又有宗教因素了。
So he's a trainee priest. He was a seminarian at one point. And so his nickname is the Mad Monk. The Mad Monk. And I see you've written in the notes, quite daily mail in his political views. So the thing for which he is notorious in Australia is that he reintroduced knighthoods and damehoods, which Gough Whitlam had got rid of. And the person he gives the knighthood to is friend of the show and God, philip which is such an odd one yeah but you think prince
所以他是个见习神父。他曾一度是修道院学生。所以他的绰号是“疯苦行僧”。“疯苦行僧”。我看到你在笔记里写了，他的政治观点非常《每日邮报》风格。所以在澳大利亚，他最臭名昭著的一件事是，他恢复了爵士和女爵士头衔，而戈夫·惠特兰曾废除了这些头衔。他授予爵士头衔的人是节目之友兼上帝，菲利普亲王，这真是个奇怪的人选。是的，但你想想菲利普
philip you know i mean he probably doesn't need it no i know that it's a very odd that he wouldn't be the first if i were prime minister of australia i brought back knighthoods which i would i don't think prince philip would be the first no shane warne arisene. What did I suppose to say? Arise, Sir Shane. Yeah. Could you give Ian Botham an Australian knighthood? That's what I'd do. I don't think he'd accept it, would he? No, of course he wouldn't. He's a slight climate change sceptic. Why give Prince
亲王，你知道的，我的意思是，他可能并不需要这个。不，我知道，这真的很奇怪，如果我是澳大利亚首相，我恢复了爵士头衔，我想我不会让菲利普亲王排在第一位。不，肖恩·沃恩，崛起吧。我该说什么来着？崛起吧，肖恩爵士。是的。你能授予伊恩·博瑟姆一个澳大利亚爵士头衔吗？这就是我要做的。我想他不会接受的，对吧？不，他当然不会。他是一个轻度的气候变化怀疑论者。为什么要把荣誉授予菲利普
Philip an honour when he's already... I don't know, Dominic, calm down! Prince Philip is already... He's not only a god, he's a prince. He doesn't need the knighthood. No. Well, this is why it was controversial in Australia. They were all saying exactly the same... He's not only a god, he's a prince. He doesn't need the knighthood. No. Well, this is why it was controversial in Australia. They were all saying exactly the same. It's absolute madness.
亲王，当他已经……我不知道，多米尼克，冷静点！菲利普亲王已经……他不仅是个神，他还是个亲王。他不需要爵士头衔。不。好吧，这就是为什么这在澳大利亚引起了争议。每个人都在说完全相同的话……他不仅是个神，他还是个亲王。他不需要爵士头衔。不。好吧，这就是为什么这在澳大利亚引起了争议。每个人都在说完全相同的话。这简直是疯了。
Right, carry on, Tom. Sorry, I... Well, I was saying about the climate change stuff, that obviously the Australian economy is booming in large part. It's not just the kind of careful stewardship of Kevin Rudd and John Howard or whatever. It's because China's appetite for the raw materials that australia can supply china with is is absolutely voracious australia is therefore you know the economy is dependent on doing kind of things that environmentalists want them to stop doing yeah which is also why
好啦，继续吧，汤姆。对不起，我……好吧，我刚才说的是气候变化方面的事情，澳大利亚经济在很大程度上蓬勃发展，显然不仅仅是因为凯文·陆克文和约翰·霍华德之流的谨慎治理，而是因为中国对澳大利亚能够提供的原材料的需求简直是饕餮般的。因此澳大利亚的经济，你知道的，依赖于做一些环保主义者希望他们停止的事情，是的。这也是为什么
another theme in australian politics over the past decade past decade means that kind of fires, bushfires, whatever, rising temperatures are very politically sensitive. They're not seen as just acts of God. They're seen as divine punishment for Western Australia's mining industry. But of course, Western Australia is dependent
过去十年澳大利亚政治中的另一个主题，过去十年意味着火灾、森林大火等等，气温上升在政治上非常敏感。它们不被视为单纯的天灾，而是被视为对西澳大利亚采矿业的神圣惩罚。当然，西澳大利亚又依赖于
on that very industry. And the difficulty for the politicians is that they're they're caught aren't they between the demands of fighting climate change but also you know it's it's a tough gig for any politician to say it is a tough gig you know part of your you need to give up this incredibly i think i think as an australian politician you have two alternatives one is to be a hypocrite or one is to be kind of say it's all nonsense right and tony abbott was that it's all nonsense. And Tony Abbott was the it's all nonsense school. But the other thing for which Abbott is probably most famous in Britain at the moment, because he's quite an influence on Priti Patel and Bryce Johnson trying to solve migrants coming over in boats from Calais, is Operation Sovereign Borders, which is the policy that people
这个行业本身。对政治家来说，难点在于他们陷入了两难境地，既要应对气候变化的要求，但你也知道，对任何政治家来说，要说出这番话都是一项艰难的任务。这确实是一项艰难的任务，你知道的，你的一部分……你必须放弃这个令人难以置信的……我想，我认为作为一名澳大利亚政客，你有两种选择：要么做一个伪君子，要么就说这纯属无稽之谈。托尼·阿博特就属于“这纯属无稽之谈”派。但阿博特在英国目前最著名的另一件事，是因为他对普里蒂·帕特尔和鲍里斯·约翰逊试图解决从加莱乘船渡海而来的移民问题有着相当大的影响，那就是“主权边境行动”，这项政策规定
who get picked up in boats get taken to, they're not brought to Australia. They're kind of given to processing centre outside Australia. Yes. And that's obviously been, you know, very influential on... The only way to dissuade people seeking to come from afar is not to let them in. That's Abbott's credo, isn't it? Yeah.
那些在船上被拦截的人将被带走，他们不会被带到澳大利亚，而是被送到澳大利亚境外的处理中心。是的。这显然对……产生了很大的影响。劝阻远道而来的人的唯一方法就是不让他们入境。这就是阿博特的信条，不是吗？是的。
So, I mean, certainly from the perspective of a Julia Gillard, he's a kind of unregenerate pitbull of a right-wing politician. I mean, I suppose what you get with Australian politics, though, which is in a way you could argue quite refreshing, is that it's so full-throated compared with let's say british politics isn't it it's so kind of unapologetically what it is so the right-wing politicians are incredibly right-wing or or at least you know their rhetoric is incredibly you know sort of full-on and the same is true i think with the left-wing politicians i mean you see these i said before about the
所以，我的意思是，至少从朱莉娅·吉拉德的角度来看，他是一个无可救药的右翼政客。我的意思是，我认为澳大利亚政治所展现出来的特质——从某种角度来看可以说相当清新脱俗——那就是与英国政治相比，它是如此直言不讳，不是吗？它是如此毫不掩饰地展现自我，所以右翼政客极其右翼，或者至少（你知道的）他们的言论极其激进。我认为左翼政客也是如此。我的意思是，你看到了这些……我之前说过，
if you ever see footage of debates in the australian legislature i mean you see these i said before about the if you ever see footage of debates in the australian legislature i mean they're absolutely going for each other with no holds barred yeah in this sort of you know there's no sort of pretense of elegance and and sort of honorable member no they're just absolutely i mean parliamentary language paul keating called the his opponent scumbags yeah yeah yeah uh anyway so um the bloodletting continues because tony abbott after two years in power gets knifed by um another liberal who's kind of liberal-ish so more moderate could it could as easily have become a labor politician um a guy called malcolm turnbull yeah who is in australia Australia. So he is the second Australian prime minister
如果你看过澳大利亚立法机构辩论的录像，我的意思是，你看到了这些……我之前说过，如果你看过澳大利亚立法机构辩论的录像，我的意思是，他们绝对是在毫无保留地互撕，是的，在这种（你知道的）没有丝毫优雅和“尊敬的议员”之类伪装的情况下，不，他们绝对是……我的意思是，议会语言……保罗·基廷称他的对手为“人渣”，是的，无论如何……呃，所以，流血事件仍在继续，因为托尼·阿博特在掌权两年后，被另一位有点自由派倾向的自由党人干掉了——也就是更温和一些、本来同样完全可以加入工党的一位名叫马尔科姆·特恩布尔的家伙，是的，他在澳大利亚
to have gone to Brasenose College in Oxford. And he was prime minister of Australia at the same time as David Cameron, who also went to Brasenose College. Were they there at the same time? That's the question. No, but they're prime ministers at the same time. And they are one of two pairings of prime ministers
。所以他是第二位毕业于牛津大学布雷齐诺斯学院的澳大利亚首相。而且他担任澳大利亚首相的时间与同样毕业于布雷齐诺斯学院的大卫·卡梅伦重合。他们当时在同一时间上学吗？这就是问题所在。没有，但他们是在同一时间担任首相。他们是两对
who both went to the same Oxford College. Do you know the other? So the ministers who both went to the same Oxford College. Do you know the other? So the two prime ministers went to the same college and they were prime ministers at the same time. They're two Commonwealth prime ministers or two Anglo-Australian. Commonwealth. Commonwealth. I'll give you a clue. They're both women.
都毕业于同一所牛津学院的首相组合之一。你知道另一对吗？所以这两位首相都毕业于同一所牛津学院。你知道另一对吗？所以这两位首相毕业于同一所学院，而且他们同时担任首相。他们是两位英联邦首相，或者两位英澳……英联邦。英联邦。我给你个提示。他们都是女性。
So it's Theresa May. No. No. Margaret Thatcher. Margaret Thatcher. Somerville. Yeah. So Somerville and. No. No. Margaret Thatcher. Margaret Thatcher. Somerville. Yeah. Is it Somerville?
所以是特雷莎·梅。不是。不是。玛格丽特·撒切尔。玛格丽特·撒切尔。萨默维尔学院。是的。所以是萨默维尔和……不是。不是。玛格丽特·撒切尔。玛格丽特·撒切尔。萨默维尔学院。是的。是萨默维尔吗？
And Indira Gandhi. Oh, golly, that is a good fact. That's a great. That is a very good fact. There's a great drama to be written there, Tom, about them reminiscing about their days at Somerville together. So the other thing for which Malcolm Turnbull is famous in Britain is that he played a leading role in defending Peter Wright,
还有英迪拉·甘地。哦，天哪，这是一个很好的事实。这太棒了。这真是一个非常好的事实。汤姆，这里面可以写成一出精彩的戏剧，讲他们回忆在萨默维尔学院的日子。马尔科姆·特恩布尔在英国著名的另一件事是，他在为彼得·赖特辩护时发挥了主导作用。
who was a rather seedy MI5 agent yeah or was he MI6 I can't remember who who published a book called Spycatcher which you'll know all about Dominic because it's it's all about Harold Wilson yes he claimed that he and uh lots of other MI5 agents had conspired against Harold Wilson when Harold Wilson was Prime minister of britain in the 1970s and so mrs satcher brought in the official secrets act didn't she yes to try and said you can't publish it and so he published it in australia and so the full might of the british uh um civil service kind of the the most elegant yes minister type mandarins went over there and were humiliated by turnbull it Is it economical with the truth?
彼得·赖特是一个相当卑劣的军情五处特工，是的，还是军情六处？我记不清了。他出版了一本书叫《捕谍者》，多米尼克，你对此一定很了解，因为这全关于哈罗德·威尔逊。是的，他声称他和许多其他军情五处特工在20世纪70年代哈罗德·威尔逊担任英国首相期间曾密谋反对哈罗德·威尔逊。因此撒切尔夫人引入了《官方保密法》，不是吗？是的，试图并声称你不能出版它。于是他在澳大利亚出版了这本书，因此英国公务员队伍的全部力量——那些最优雅的“大臣”式的高级官员——跑到那里，却被特恩布尔羞辱了。这是对真相的精打细算吗？
I think Robert Armstrong, the Robert Armstrong, who was head of the British Civil Service, was kind of admitted basically to having lied. So it was all a disaster. And on top of that, Turnbull was a very prominent Republican. Which is interesting given that he's on the right of Australian politics. Yeah. So that's why he could easily have been Labour.
我认为罗伯特·阿姆斯特朗——英国公务员队伍的负责人——基本上承认自己撒谎了。所以这简直是一场灾难。最重要的是，特恩布尔是一个非常著名的共和主义者。考虑到他属于澳大利亚政治的右翼，这就很有趣了。是的，所以这就是为什么他很容易加入工党。
Because he was the chair wasn't he of the campaign for a republic and because they had a referendum in 1999 yeah so yes he's very much on the sort of the the softer wing i suppose of the australian right but surprise surprise he doesn't sit easily on the on the throne for long does he what has he got three years and then he's knifed by the abbots the, does he? What has he got, three years? And then he's knifed by the abbots, the abbotists. What were the abbotists? Yes. Would they be called the abbotists?
因为他曾担任共和国运动的主席，不是吗？因为他们在1999年举行了一场公投。是的，所以他非常支持澳大利亚右翼中较为温和的一翼，我想。但不出所料，他在王位上并没有坐多久，不是吗？他当了三年，然后就被阿博特派给干掉了。阿博特派是什么？是的。他们会被称为“阿博特主义者”吗？
I suppose, yes. The abbotards. The bad monks. And he was succeeded by Scott Morrison. Now, Scott Morrison has, of course, as our listeners will now know. May he no longer be prime minister. There will no Scott Morrison's fate. By the time you listen to this.
我想，是的。阿博特分子。疯苦行僧。接替他的是斯科特·莫里森。现在，正如我们的听众现在所知道的那样，斯科特·莫里森。愿他不再担任首相。到你听到这个节目时，斯科特·莫里森的命运就已经尘埃落定了。
And I have to say of Scott Morrison, to me, he just looks like a man at a garden center i don't really have anything to say about he looks like a koala do you think so yeah he knocked somebody over he looked he knocked a child over he was playing football and he kind of he did a boris johnson basically yes and also that was very funny he was he was out campaigning and giving a speech on uh on a lawn and the bloke whose lawn it was came out and said, get off my lawn. Yes, that's true. So that was fun. That was very nicely sort of egalitarian Australian, I thought.
我不得不说斯科特·莫里森，对我来说，他看起来就像一个在园艺中心的人，我对他的外表真的没什么好说的。他看起来像只考拉，你觉得呢？是的，他把人撞倒了。他看起来……他撞倒了一个小孩，当时他在踢足球，他基本上做了一个鲍里斯·约翰逊式的动作。是的，而且那非常搞笑，他当时正在外面参加竞选，并在草坪上发表演讲，结果那片草坪的主人走出来说：“从我的草坪上滚开。”是的，这是真的。所以那很有趣。我觉得这非常具有澳大利亚式的平等主义色彩。
He did just get off the lawn. He was like, oh, sorry, and he got off the lawn. But he seems the kind of man to whom these things happen. Slightly gaffe-brained. So his big gaffe was that in 2019-20, that summer in Australia, there were terrible, terrible bushfires. And you remember talking koalas, all the koalas burnt to death. It was absolutely awful, kind of the highest temperatures Australia had ever known. And he was on holiday in Hawaii.
他真的就从草坪上走开了。他当时就像是“哦，对不起”，然后就离开了草坪。但他似乎就是那种会发生这种事的人。有点爱出洋相。所以他最大的洋相是，在2019-20年，澳大利亚的那年夏天，发生了非常非常可怕的森林大火。你还记得那些会说话的考拉吗？所有的考拉都被烧死了。这绝对太可怕了，那是澳大利亚有史以来最高的温度。而他却在夏威夷度假。
Oh, that's right, yes. And this did not go down well. And the other thing, I guess, for which he's recently been, I mean, he had a good COVID, I think. I mean, he managed it quite well. He maintained Fortress Australia and then brought the vaccine in. So Australia's death rate's been much lower than it was in Europe. But he, and Alcas, you said the submarine deal. Oh, yeah.
哦，对的，是的。这可不太受欢迎。另一件事，我想，他最近一直在……我的意思是，他度过了一个不错的新冠时期。我的意思是，他处理得很好。他维持了“澳大利亚堡垒”的状态，然后引进了疫苗。所以澳大利亚的死亡率比欧洲低得多。但他，还有阿尔卡斯，你提到的潜艇协议。哦，是的。
He annoyed the French. Yeah. But he kind of presided over the Djokokovic debacle right that's right yes was it a debacle i mean well i think he was trying to leverage it because he had the election coming up and he thought it would play well yeah i think they all got scrambled with kind of government you know uh federal and state that's right yeah levels so anyway and also he's a pentecostalist is he does he speak in tongues I don't know if he does. I mean, I think he kind of periodically in interviews,
他惹恼了法国人。是的。但他基本上主导了德约科维奇事件，对吧？没错，是的。那是一场惨败吗？嗯，我认为他当时是想借此施加政治影响力，因为大选就要到了，他认为这会产生好的效果。是的，我认为他们都被政府的各种部门搞得焦头烂额，你知道的，联邦和州的层面，没错，是的。无论如何，还有他是一个五旬节派信徒，他会说方言吗？我不知道他会不会。我的意思是，我想他在采访中定期
he's intimated that he does. But he's never done it in an interview. Yeah. He does think that trolls on social media are literally emanations of the devil. Well, that will be a relief to you, Tom, when you get abuse from academics. Yeah. Satan is speaking. Yeah so so we'll see so the question is i mean obviously that culture of spills is ridiculous and probably very damaging to good government because it just means you know prime ministers have come and go within two years and presumably spent an enormous amount
暗示过他会。但他从没在采访中展示过。是的。他真的认为社交媒体上的喷子简直是魔鬼的化身。好吧，汤姆，当你受到学者们的谩骂时，这倒能让你松口气。是的。撒旦在发言。是的，所以……所以我们将拭目以待。问题是，显然那种逼宫的文化是荒谬的，并且可能对良好的政府治理极具破坏性，因为这意味着首相们两年内就会走马灯似地换来换去，想必他们有大量时间
of time watching their backs watching their backs do, I mean, we talked about some of these Robert Menzies and, you know, Bob Hawke and so on, Goff Whitlam. Do you think it's fair to say that the standard has declined? I don't know enough about Australian politics to say that. But my feeling is that we always think that the politicians who are more recent are less effective. Of course we do of course because we always can't you know we're already we're looking back and saying oh you know remember
都在提防背后捅刀子，提防背后捅刀子。我是说，我们谈到了一些这样的人物，比如罗伯特·孟席斯，还有（你知道的）鲍勃·霍克等等，戈夫·惠特兰。你觉得说水准下降了是否公允？我对澳大利亚政治了解不够，无法下此定论。但我的感觉是，我们总觉得最近的政客效率更低。我们当然会这么觉得，因为我们总是忍不住（你知道的）回顾过去，然后说“哦，你瞧，还记得特雷莎·梅吗？特雷莎·梅那是多么黄金的年代啊，杰里米·科尔宾……他们曾经是多么伟大的巨擘啊”。嗯，我想，因为人们经常这样评价英国政治，在过去十年左右的时间里，英国政坛高层也非常不稳定，我脑海中浮现的一点就是——我的意思是，确实，人们总是说水准在下降，从来没有哪个时代的人不哀叹政治领导力的崩溃。但人们总是这么说，并不意味着它就不是真的，并不意味着政治水准永远不会下降。我的意思是，我认为凯文·陆克文、朱莉娅·吉拉德、马尔科姆·特恩布尔、斯科特·莫里森、托尼·阿博特，他们和那些首相具有相同的威望吗？他们真的和20世纪40年代和50年代的首相具备相同的威望吗？
theresa may what golden days of theresa may and jeremy corbyn what giants they were well i think i mean because people often say this about british politics which has also been very unstable in the last 10 years or so at the top and the one thing that occurs to me is just i mean it's true people have always said the standards have were falling there's never a point where people didn't bemoan the collapse in political leadership. But the fact that people always say it doesn't therefore mean that it's not true, that it can never fall. I mean, I think Kevin Rudd, Julia Gillard, Malcolm Turnbull, Scott Morrison, Tony Abbott, are they of the same stature as the prime ministers? Are they genuinely of the same stature as the prime ministers of the 1940s and 1950s?
或者我们这么说仅仅是因为背景不同，因为我们不那么崇敬权威了？（你知道的）这些都是难题。我认为霍克和基廷显然是杰出的政治家，但他们也是非凡的政治家。他们不仅仅是政客。他们是政治艺术的大师，而且他们把这种艺术运用到了具有巨大影响力的目标上，不仅在澳大利亚政治的语境中，而且在国际上也是如此。是的，从某种意义上说，他们为克林顿、布莱尔、施罗德以及所有这一类传统开辟了道路。我认为此后澳大利亚的
Or are we only saying that because the context is different because we're less deferential? You know, these are difficult questions. I think Hawking and Keating were clearly exceptional politicians, but also exceptional. They weren't just politicians. They were masters of the art of politics but they put it to to purposes that were very influential not just you know within the context of australian politics but internationally yeah so in a sense they blazed the path for clinton and blair and schroeder and all that kind of tradition um and i think that that since then australia's
环境——由于它拥有这一切矿产资源以及它与中国的这种关系——意味着它与欧洲或美国等地的趋势稍微脱钩了。但我认为，与中国的这种关系——自联邦成立之初起就是澳大利亚政治中的一个议题——再次变得更加不稳定，这就是为什么斯科特·莫里森签署了那个协议。奥库斯协议。是的，奥库斯协议。
circumstances because of its you know it has all these mineral resources and it has this relationship with china has meant that it slightly uncoupled itself from trends within say europe or america right but i think that that relationship with china which has been an issue in australian politics right from the point of federation is becoming more unstable again, which is why Scott Morrison signed that. The AUKUS. Yeah, the AUKUS deal.
好吧，我们显然还不知道澳大利亚大选的结果。当我们制作第一期播客时，我们以为这会在澳大利亚大选之后播出。我的意思是，可能已经换了好几位首相了。是的，所以第一批收听这个节目的听众，将会在大选结束后
Okay. Well, we don't know, obviously, the results of the Australian election. When we did our first podcast, we thought this would be coming out in the wake of the Australian. I mean, there may have been several prime ministers. Yeah. So the first one we'll look at this will be what four or five days
大约四五天听到它。是的，考虑到他们热衷于……是的，考虑到他们热衷于背后捅刀子。但对我来说，真正让我大开眼界的是澳大利亚政治竟然如此有趣，而讽刺的是，在英国我们对它一无所知，并且认为它无聊得令人难以置信。是的，绝对如此，我认为确实如此。但我认为它相当具有影响力，所以我想，你知道的，我们讨论过，托尼·阿博特的移民政策对这里的保守党产生了影响；霍克-基廷政府对布莱尔和布朗产生了非常非常大的影响；所以我想，毫无疑问，
after the elections yeah so who knows given their enthusiasm yeah given their enthusiasm for stabbing the other in the back but the thing that i suppose the real for me the real revelation of this is just how incredibly interesting australian politics is and the the irony that in britain we are so ignorant of it and we think of it as just unbelievably boring yeah absolutely i think it's true but i think it has been quite influential so i think you know we talked tony abbott's immigration policies have been influential on conservatives here um the hawk keating governments were very very influential on blair and brown um so i think that, you know, absolutely,
政客们当然对澳大利亚保持着警惕。是的。太好了。好吧，非常感谢你们陪我们度过了原本打算轻松畅聊的三集节目。是的，所以，多米尼克，当我们开始做这个播客时，
politicians certainly are alert to Australia. Yeah. Jolly good. All right. Well, thank you very much for bearing with us for three episodes of what was meant to be a short gallop. Yes. So, I mean, Dominic, when we began this podcast,
你想过我们会做三集还是没想到？我没想过，但我的意思是，那是好几天前的事了。音乐先生，请你用迪吉里杜管再给我们最后吹奏一曲，把我们送出节目，好吗？好的。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
would you have thought we'd do three episodes or not? I didn't, but I mean, that was several days ago. So will you give us one more blast, please, Mr Music, of your didgeridoo to play us out? Okay. Goodbye. Good day. Good day. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝演艺界八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告畅听、加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。